we know that fiber is a main ingredient
for creating a healthy microbiome that's
really not up for debate
it's becoming more and more clear as
time goes on that the microbes in our
gut have way more control over our
bodies biological processes than we
originally thought or might like to
believe including as it turns out immune
system functionality are resistance to
infection and illness if your complement
of gut bacteria are off and you don't
have a healthy microbiome your immune
system might not trigger that release of
virus slaying capabilities to better
understand this connection between our
microbiome and our immune system I sat
down with Robin shutkin MD Robin is a
board-certified gastroenterologist who
serves on the faculty at Georgetown
University hospital she is the founder
of the digestive Center for wellness as
well as the author of The book's gut
Bliss microbiome solution the bloat cure
and her most recent the antiviral gut
which is the central topic of this
conversation and offers practical advice
for optimizing diet exercise sleep and
time Outdoors to boost the body's
defenses and our overall health most of
the immune system is physically located
in your gut about 70 to 80 percent of it
and there's constant communication so
the gut bacteria actually guide that
immune response they're constantly
sending signals to the immune cells to
tell them what to do we've talked a lot
about the microbiome on this podcast but
I would say that today's exchange is
truly a master class within itself we
discuss how the gut is affected by birth
control
sleep stress lifestyle and diet as well
as various medications including NSAIDs
like ibuprofen and ppis like Prilosec
and we end with advice on how to seek
treatment for a gut issue I've known
Robin for a number of years she is such
a delightful presence and it was a treat
to have her here again for her second
appearance on the podcast Robin's
expertise in communicating on this
subject matter is unparalleled and I'm
very excited to share this one with you
so please hit that subscribe button and
enjoy this deep dive into the antiviral
gut with Dr Robin
[Music]
so nice to have you here it's so great
to be here I was reflecting on the last
time that we did this it was a full
seven years ago I remember showing up at
your house in DC and meeting your family
being very intimidated by your husband
who I believe is like in
counterterrorism for the CIA like he's a
super spy he was he still doing that or
DHS DHS and now he's with midar but he's
just a pussycat do you remember remember
my daughter I think she was 10 at the
time and I remember you got out of a car
I think an Uber and she was all like
what he didn't swim up the Potomac and
bike and run and she was all
disappointed that you hadn't like come
on civilian yeah
um I can't believe how long ago that was
it feels like yesterday but delighted to
have you back we're here because you've
got this new book out a lot has happened
over the last seven years in terms of
your life and also
advances in the science of the
microbiome it really is like this
amazing Frontier right now where so much
is coming out
um about how important gut health is uh
for every facet of Health we're going to
focus on the immune system today the
antiviral gut your book but maybe catch
us up on what what's going on in your
life since we last talked and and maybe
uh you know what's been going on in the
in the field of microbiome science in
2015 I think my second book The
microbiome solution had just come out
and I think people were just sort of
like huh right got microbes it was a New
Concept yeah I mean obviously we've
known about the microbiome now really
from the 1600s when Anthony Von Leven
hook first looked at his own Dental
plaque onto the microscope and saw some
Critters but you know as you pointed out
Rich it's really taken a while and now
we're in this Crescendo phase so there's
a really cool graph online it sort of
floats around the internet of the number
of medical articles published scientific
articles on the microbiome and you know
it's like a bar graph and then you just
see it like stacking up and now of
course in the last two years that's just
gone through the ceiling right the
scientific literature and in some ways a
scientific literature has caught up with
what we know to be true because we we
see it we live it we experience it all
the time and so I actually have gone
back and read that second book which
until this book was the favorite of my
four books and and realize like how much
of that maybe just sort of didn't
penetrate for people really until this
pandemic so it's it's actually kind of
tragic right that it's taken a global
pandemic like this in some ways for
people to really realize this stuff
matters and yet I'm I'm not sure I'm
convinced that the pandemic really
connected people with with the
importance of the microbiome and its
relationship to the immune system I mean
this is a big focus of the book right
like I learned a lot reading it I mean
first of all fabulous job it's I think
it's you know an incredible read and I
learned a ton
um and you know on the subject of of
kind of how science has advanced
um
it is it is like the new and the old
right like you even have the quote in
the book like Hippocrates saying like
all disease begins in the gut like this
is not a new idea all this science is
coming out and yet it does also feel
like we're still at the starting line
like I feel like there's so much more
that we still don't know that we're
discovering like every month something
new comes out some Revelation about how
important uh our our gut health is in
relationship to every other facet of
well-being and that was part of the
challenge of writing this book quite
frankly this idea of the science moving
so fast so I like the other three books
which are primarily about Digestive
Health something I've been in this field
for 30 years I dare say I know what I'm
talking about this science was changing
I literally wake up in the morning and
there'd be you know 10U research
articles for me to read and by that
night there would be more and then the
next day I would wake up again and I
remember commenting to my daughter who's
now a senior in high school I think she
was probably finishing up her sophomore
year year when I started this process
and I remember commenting to her and
sort of complaining that I feel like I'm
writing a 20-page research article every
day and she very
um kind of sarcastically said well
welcome to my world maybe she was a
junior in high school right but it
really did feel that way but at the same
time it was incredibly exciting because
seeing these fields of immunology and
microbiology and gastroenterology all
coming together neurology quite frankly
coming together and I also felt that
there was a fervor not just in the
medical and scientific Community but out
there with people to get answers and to
find out and you can see it it's
reflected in the in the publishing
process and in the way that articles now
are more accessible right and of course
a peer-reviewed process is important we
need to make sure we need to validate
when a new article comes out that the
statistics are correct that the figures
are correct that peer review process is
super important but at the same time
it's super important to get the info
Mission out to people quickly and I
think this this concept of the citizen
scientist you know of of I mean I'm just
amazed at my patients how much they know
and how much they've read and they're
reading a lot of the same journals I'm
reading I mean maybe they don't have the
same scientific medical background to
interpret it the same way but they're
interested there's this kind of thirst
and fervor to find out that just feels
different from where we've been before
that can go both ways though right like
you can have the person who goes down
the wrong rabbit hole and gets a bunch
of strange ideas in their head about
what they should be doing I mean that
seems to be you know a big problem at
the moment like what is fact what is
fiction and when you you know kind of
peruse
um uh you know news articles that are
extracting from the peer-reviewed
research they don't always translate it
properly and there tends to be
clickbaity headlines associated with
that stuff that give people maybe
misguided advice absolutely and then
there's a Commerce piece you know there
have been huge fortunes made as you know
from you know whatever it is like
whatever this sort of magic pill at the
moment is for curing coved and as you
said the click bait you know the
sensationalism the the goal for me for
this book was pretty simple I just want
to give people information that they can
use and the tone is you know I feel calm
and reassured right I mean there was as
time has gone on I think we felt more
that way there was certainly I think a
lot of Terror in the beginning but it is
and it's not just about covet it's about
your body right the more you know how it
works the unit the more you know that
these things that are happening are
primarily designed to help you not to
hinder you and the more you understand
it can have that dialogue the better off
you are and that's true about covid
about cancer about you know the common
cold whatever it is that's going on and
really making sure that people
understand some of the physiological the
anatomical the hormonal processes that
are going on sure sure so the subject of
the microbiome is not a new uh you know
theme for this show I've hosted many
conversations on this subject matter
including yourself and we did a master
class on it not too long ago but what we
haven't done is really go deep into the
relationship between gut health and the
immune system and obviously this is the
focus of the book so let's like start
with just defining our terms a little
bit like when you say okay we we kind of
know what the microbiome is we're going
to get into that we kind of know what
the immune system is but like do we like
the immune system isn't it's sort of uh
it's sort of a femor right it's not like
the pancreas like where is the immune
system what does it do exactly it's
dispersed to some extent it's
complicated it's really multiple systems
operating so talk a little bit about
like what we mean when we talk about the
immune system sure and I think you did a
fantastic job of describing exactly how
people perceive it it is this ephemeral
kind of it's humors lurking around in
the body somewhere but most of the
immune system is physically located in
your gut about 70 to 80 percent of it
and so when we talk about the immune
system we do a little Immunology 101 and
you know full disclosure I'm not an
immunologist I'm a gastroenterologist
but let me give folks some Basics so
we're really talking about two systems
we're talking about the innate immune
system that you're born with and an
acquired immune system sometimes called
the Adaptive immune system that you
acquire over time the innate immune
system works quickly but it's sort of
non-specific so for example if you get a
cut it it works to help protect you from
the bacteria that may be invading
through that open wound but in a very
non-specific way
the acquired immune system develops over
time and it actually keeps a record of
every pathogen that you're exposed to so
that it can remember it and mount a
response so it's sort of like that
person who never forgets and holds a
grudge and is like oh yeah in first
grade you kick me onto the table right
like in a crow like crows never forget
exactly
so the acquired immune system
is able to it takes a little bit longer
to work and particularly if it's a new
organism but it it remembers and then it
is able to release antibodies so the
acquired immune system involves T
lymphocytes B lymphocytes and the B ones
make the antibodies and the T
lymphocytes are kind of like air traffic
control destroying cells that have been
infected Etc but but if you think about
the Adaptive immune system the point
that I like to make for people is that
that is a basis of vaccines for example
right a vaccine introduces a tiny little
bit of the viral protein not enough
ideally to make you sick but enough for
your adaptive immune system to start to
create antibodies against it for the
next time it encounters that virus and
so if you think about some of these
things like with measles for example a
virus that's very old you get measles
and you you know have the illness your
immune system remember so that the next
time you're exposed to measles you're
immune now vaccine can do the same thing
right but so can having the disease in
that particular instance and so what we
see is that the Adaptive immune system
can make you less sick or not sick at
all the next time you encounter
something sure so the innate immune
system the acquired immune system
so when we talk about you I think you
said 70 yeah the immune system resides
in the gut like so what is it exactly
that is in the gut is it these
lymphocytes is it these you know systems
and Pathways like what are we talking
about it's these actual cells so when
you think about the gut lining this is a
razor thin lining it is literally you
know a millimeter or too thick and it's
a net it's a permeable net like a
fishing net with tiny holes and it
allows some things to go through so
typically digested food digested into
the micronutrients passes through and
then the the excrement the waste matter
from cells passes out and remember that
when something is in your GI tract it's
not actually inside your body it's in
this Long Hollow tube from mouth to anus
and so things get passed out well the
immune cells are on one side they're on
the inside part of the net inside your
body and your trillions of microbes are
on the outside on the other side of the
gut lining and of course there's a thick
mucous layer are also surrounding the
gut microbes but it is literally this
hand and glove relationship and there's
constant communication so the gut
bacteria actually guide that immune
response they're constantly sending
signals to the immune cells to tell them
what to do and I'll give you a great
example of that
is there is a bacteria in the gut called
bacteroidities it's a sort of type of
bacteria and there are many different
strains and when certain viruses enter
the GI tract back to rightes in the gut
lining right there you know in the Lumen
against the lining will trigger a
message
interferons and they're called
interferons because they interfere with
viruses to release certain cytokines to
destroy the viruses and so if your
complement of gut bacteria are off and
you don't have a healthy microbiome and
you don't have sufficient quantities or
the right strains of bacteroidities you
might not trigger that release of
interferons and the sort of virus
slaying capabilities if you will so it
is it's both a functional relationship
and it's an actual physical relationship
Rich because they're right there next to
each other constantly communicating and
when you think about it your immune
system your gut Lumen is exposed to
trillions of different things right
because again it's in contact with the
environment what we're eating and
swallowing
everything's going into this open tube
and your immune system has to look at
this morass of you know a gazillion
different organisms and figure out
what's friend and what's Foe and it's
really the gut microbiome that is
directing that and that's literally
saying yeah this one you need to be
really worried do something big this one
just ignore yeah this one's actually
helping so it's that back and forth
relationship that communication that's
happening all the time in our gut right
so essentially these things are
completely interwoven you can't talk
about the gut without talking about the
immune system and vice versa they're 100
dependent upon each other in terms of
their functionality and when we talk
about uh immune system dysregulation
that can come in two forms either it's
hyperactive and then you see all of
these like sort of autoimmune diseases
or allergies to foods and such the
cytokine storm that comes with you know
certain people who succumb to covid Etc
or the underperforming immune system
that you mentioned where you're not
producing the interferons and the
cytokines necessary to combat the
disease on the front lines the virus on
the front lines is that yeah that's a
that's a beautiful summary and I I think
even dividing it further into internal
threats and external threats can can
help to clarify it even more but you you
gave a beautiful summary of what it is
so if we think about an overactive
immune system
on the one hand I want people to think
about internal threats and that would
manifest as autoimmune disease so that's
basically when your body is reacting to
your own body's normal tissue it's
recognizing your own joint skin Etc as
foreign and mounting an immune response
and so we see that with autoimmune
disease effect one in four Americans
there are over 100 different autoimmune
diseases now and this is a list that's
growing unfortunately
we can talk about why that's happening
later when we look still in the category
of an overactive immune system we look
at external threats and so that would be
people are having allergies peanut
allergies severe allergies to bee stings
I was
exploring the marsh in Beaufort South
Carolina my husband's Hometown Back in
May and we had the uh we had the
unfortunate
uh privilege of being bitten up by
chiggers these insects and his healed in
about two or three weeks and mine are
still active four months later I have
this sort of unknown delayed
hypersensitivity reaction to it and and
maybe because he grew up in South
Carolina and he's been bitten by
chiggers before as a kid and I never
have but that's an example of an
exaggerated response to this external
threat so that's all overactive immune
system
under active immune system if we again
look at the two categories of internal
threat and external threat the internal
threat would be people developing cancer
because your immune system doesn't just
protect you from infection it also helps
with cancer surveillance so as our cells
start dividing sometimes they start to
divide a little precariously and that
reproduction leads to errors in the
genetic material of the cell and over
time that can transform to cancer and so
the internal cancer surveillance system
is also something that our immune system
does and it would weed out those cells
so that they die off and they're not
continuing to proliferate and form
cancer so with an underactive immune
system your cancer surveillance is off
and your increases the cancer on the
internal side and on the external side
that would be infection viral bacterial
fungal Etc so what what we're should all
be aiming for is this concept of a
Goldilocks immune system right an immune
system that is active enough to clear a
virus
but not so active that we end up with a
cytokine storm you mentioned this
overblown immune response and the Really
fascinating thing when we look at this
pandemic is that a lot of the deaths and
the illness have been due primarily to
the immune response not so much a virus
itself but it's our body's unregulated
or dysregulated response to that virus
that's causing the acute respiratory
distress syndrome or you know other
severe illnesses and sometimes even
death yeah sure so there's so much in
what he just said to to unpack but to
kind of uh pull some threads on this I
mean first of all uh yes like in you
know in this era of covid I think we can
all agree that we've been on the
receiving end of a lot of conflicting
information and social vitriol that kind
of swirled around what is fact what is
fiction certainly you know one truth
that was kind of underrepresented was
that there was not enough messaging
about
the personal responsibility that we have
for our own health and much of what you
talk about and is in your book is the
malleability the adaptability of the gut
microbiome and in turn our immune system
when we sort of get rid of certain
things or stop certain habits and adapt
new habits like it really is resilient
in that regard and we're all capable of
of you know creating a Goldilocks immune
system we I mean most of it most of the
languaging is around boosting our immune
system obviously that's problematic for
the reasons that you just said it is
this Goldilocks immune system that we're
all striving for but to kind of begin to
understand this I think we have to talk
about it seems to me that the first
place that we want to kind of enter into
here is the difference between germ
Theory and terrain Theory which you you
know beautifully uh articulate in the
book so let's start with that okay and I
do I can you know I can talk about that
one for hours it's a great one to talk
talk about but I just want to Circle
back to something you said which I think
is so important which is this you know
perceived Duality that if you're saying
host Health matters and that we have
some control over outcome that means
that somehow you're not saying that
vaccines and monoclonal antibodies and
so on are important and I just want to
emphasize that both of these things are
important of course and it's Common
Sense
insist on it being either or I mean if
you're
an 85 year old with heart disease who's
a smoker and Senator and overweight and
diabetic and hypertensive
and you have a heart attack you're going
to do worse than somebody who's 35 and
you know an ultra Runner who eats really
healthily Etc so host Health matters for
cancer and infection and viral illnesses
and everything else right and that's the
goal to be the healthiest host we can so
to get back to my two favorite topics of
germ Theory and terrain Theory germ
theory was really popularized by Louis
Pasteur and germ Theory basically says
that a bad bug gets into your body and
it makes you sick and that's absolutely
true and we see evidence of that all the
time we're seeing evidence of it now
with SARS cov2 mm-hmm
but terrain Theory says that a healthy
host
can manage illness and recover and
that's also true so we wash our hands if
you look at medical practices you know
we wash our hands and we sanitize things
because of germ Theory
but we also eat a healthy diet and
exercise and do all of those things
because of terrain Theory because we
want to be healthy hosts and so the two
things are really you know again they're
hand and glove they're not contrary to
each other and you know in the
scientific Community there was all this
back and forth but apparently Bishop
Antoine beshamp who popularized terrain
Theory who's also a Frenchman like Louis
Pasteur
um folks in the bishop camp and I don't
think they're two distinct camps and
they shouldn't be but they sort of are
apparently Louis Pasteur reportedly on
his deathbed said
bishanp was right terrain fairy and I
don't know if that might be a little uh
a little dramatized but clearly both
things are really important right there
are germs that get into our body that
can do us harm but our health as hosts
matters greatly in this equation and
it's also important to to realize that
not all germs are bad and a scorched
Earth approach where we you know go out
and basically try and you know seek and
destroy mission for all bacteria or
viruses can lead us to some bad places
right once again it's not a binary
dualistic thing it's not one or the
other these are both important it does
feel like in in the messaging or
conversation around covid it was pretty
much all about germ Theory and maybe not
enough about terrain Theory we can
quibble about that but it is interesting
to kind of consider the interplay
between these two you know theories that
are at play in terms of our
susceptibility to to a viral infection
and disease and what was amazing in the
book was the statistics around people
who were not healthy hosts or who had
dysbiosis or some kind of dysregulated
gut microbiome and how they ended up
faring when they came into contact with
the virus yeah it's an incredibly
predictive marker the health of the
microbiome so one of the studies that I
talk about in the book is a study that
looked at what's going on in your
microbiome as a predictor of acute
respiratory illness and even death
and the accuracy of identifying these
different organisms and the one in
particular fecalobacterium presnet CI
that's really this incredible bacterium
that's associated with eating a lot of
plant fiber and protective for other
reasons in terms of short chain fatty
acids and immune regulation high levels
of f prosnid CI were very predictive of
a good outcome and low levels the
opposite and and the accuracy in the
study was 92 percent which is much
higher than looking at age gender
comorbidity or even inflammatory markers
like the C-reactive protein Etc so they
were seeing really incredible
correlation between
this marker of a healthy microbiome an
outcome from covid and that's true for
other viral illnesses also we've seen
similar statistics for influenza for
rotavirus Etc and again we shouldn't be
surprised by that but somehow we are
when I would watch reports on television
and they you know it was I think we'll
look back at this time and and see a lot
of things we didn't do right and and one
of that was a television reporting which
was really designed to just completely
freak us out and terrorize us make us
scared and I would look at it with my
family and would say you know I bet you
this person is taking an acid blocker
has obesity is you know maybe on a on a
immuno compromising medication Etc so
again there is predictability to this
not a hundred percent of the time of
course but there are patterns that we
see when we look at some of these
factors host factors that are the
primary determinants of outcome it's not
the virulence of the virus when we take
a population of people who are exposed
to the same virus
and we look at different outcomes those
outcomes are all exposed to the same
virus those outcomes are very much
dependent on what the individual host
factors are and and many of those are
things that we can mitigate we can do
things about yeah I mean 92 percent is
quite remarkable it's very damn good and
that's without considering any other
factors right when you actually then
fold in uh you know some comorbidities
the I think the the statistic I saw is
that it goes up to like 98
predictability 93 is that what it is wow
yeah you get an extra percentage point
right so in other words we all know
people or or just you know the general
case of like
well this person you know ended up in
the ICU it doesn't have to be coveted
whatever disease right this person got
exposed and they ended up violently ill
and this other person who was standing
right next to that person
didn't
become symptomatic at all why is that
well you know who knows like genetics or
we just sort of dismiss it and what
you're saying is no actually when you
look at the gut it becomes quite clear
why some people fare better than others
absolutely and these other cofactors
obviously and it's important for people
to understand there's not blame being
assigned Terror we're not saying you
know you got sick and ended up on a
ventilator because you have obesity and
that's your fall the whole point of this
is to recognize that these are factors
that we can identify that can help us
prognosticate and more importantly that
we can remediate ideally so that this
doesn't end up happening to you again or
you recover so you know it's it's
important for people to understand that
this is not about blaming the victim
somebody gets sick from covid regardless
of their circumstances it's tragic but
it's really essential to point out and
to identify what are these factors so
that we can do risk mitigation and also
maybe we can think about our strategies
for how we approach the next pandemic
who's at high risk and who's not as
opposed to just you know blanket
recommendations yeah yeah yeah yeah well
let's get into that I mean obviously the
key thing we want to avoid is dysbiosis
dysbiosis is something that we've talked
about extensively on the show with Dr B
on your peer your colleague in this
world yeah
um so if you want to hear us go on for
hours about that you should listen to
those episodes but
um in terms of the causes like the
primary causes of dysbiosis I learned a
lot reading your book and about certain
things that I didn't know can be driving
this that are easily remediated like
let's start with ppis proton proton pump
inhibitors you already kind of
referenced it a moment ago but I was not
aware of this yeah you started with my
favorite one and I'll tell you rich a
big part of the motivation for writing
the book had to do with that pivotal
study on ppis and I I do use my husband
as a little bit of a sounding board so I
remember when that study came out in the
summer 2020 I said to him because he's
not in medicine so he's you know I'm
surrounded by a lot of medical
colleagues and we all know a lot of the
same stuff but I said to him I said
you know that if you're on an acid block
or you're going to be much more likely
to get coveted right and he was like
what
why and I said because stomach acid and
he was like I said but I kept saying but
you know that right and he goes I don't
know that how would I know that and then
I realized not only did he in a
non-medical field not know that
a lot of my medical colleagues didn't
know that a lot of my gastroenterology
colleagues didn't know that so the study
was a population-based study of about 54
000 patients
and they looked at people taking a
proton pump inhibitor
those you know you might know it as a
little purple pill so that's drugs like
Prilosec Nexium ass effects Protonix or
a whole host of them on the market and
these drugs are like an antacid right a
little an antacid technical is a little
bit different shorter acting the
difference with a proton pump inhibitors
is that they're long acting and these
drugs have been amongst the most
commonly prescribed drugs in the world
because they work amazingly well they're
an incredibly efficient class of drugs
for doing what they're supposed to do
which is shutting down that proton
potassium atpase that acid pump in your
stomach so when you take these drugs and
it takes a couple days to get levels to
the sufficient point where you
essentially have no stomach acid and so
for people who suffer from acid reflux
they love these drugs because you take
these drugs and now you can do all the
things you're not supposed to do you can
eat a big heavy meal late at night and
you feel fine
but stomach acid is there for a reason
in addition to it being one of the most
important components of digestion we
need stomach acid to provide the right
acidic milieu for the digestive enzymes
to work so the food can be broken down
to provide the right pH so the nutrients
can be assimilated and absorbed and
we've seen with these drugs what happens
when you take them long term I'm not
talking about taking this drug for a
month or six weeks because you have an
ulcer or you have bad reflux I'm talking
about people taking these drugs for
several months and the study it was
looking at people who are taking the
drug for four months or more and some
people are on these drugs for decades so
what the study found is that people
taking one of these drugs once a day
were twice as likely to have a positive
test for covid and people taking the
drugs twice a day it was a three to
four-fold increased risk and that's
because stomach acid denatures viral
proteins so when you're exposed to a lot
of these viruses the entry point for a
lot of us it can be a respiratory system
it can also be our digestive system and
in fact The ace2 receptors that bind
SARS cov2 we have about 100 times more
ac2 receptors in our GI tract than we
have in our lungs and that's why GI
symptoms have been so common with this
virus
so you're exposed to the virus it gets
in through your mouth you swallow it if
you have adequate levels of stomach acid
the acid denatures a viral protein and
can prevent it from binding to those
intestinal epithelial cells and
infecting them and creating that Cascade
of inflammation but if you're now in a
proton pump inhibitor and if you've been
on one for several months and you
essentially don't have any stomach acid
now you're defenseless because now your
stomach has been converted from a
hostile acidic environment for viruses
to a friendly alkaline environment and
so
you know I I read that study and I I
remember talking to my my literary agent
Howard Yoon about it and I was like
Howard you know people really don't know
and he said well you know maybe write an
editor you know maybe an editorial or
something and I was like yeah maybe I'll
do that I'll be good for you know spread
the word and then the other the
microbiome study came out with the
fecalobacteria and prosnitziai high
levels of that being protective and this
other bacterium enterococcus vicolis
high levels of that being negatively
predictive in the sense that those are
associated with a worse outcome and I
just felt like nobody's talking about
host health
and there's lots of people talking about
vaccines and other important things but
but this is an area that I really know a
lot about with the gut and it was just
um it just felt like that part of the
public health message was missing and
rich in some ways even worse it felt
like if you talked about that You Were
Somehow saying this other stuff
which I just don't understand because
I'm very Pro all the other things that
we have in medicine to serve us but but
making sure people understand that and
there are people who have to take these
drugs but these drugs are very over
prescribed they've been studies
suggesting that 70 80 percent of people
taking them particularly older people
over 65 who are also at risk for other
reasons that though that the majority of
the prescriptions are unnecessary and
the interesting thing about ppis rich is
we have seen for decades in the GI world
this increased risk of infection from
PPI so if you look at something like
Clostridium difficile it's a bacteria
that is off often prevalent in hospitals
and we think about it as an antibiotic
Associated diarrhea because you you take
antibiotics you wipe out a lot of your
Healthy bacteria
and then the C diff that's lurking or
that you've caught from you know a door
or something in the hospital now starts
to proliferate and lo and behold you
have the C diff colitis which you know
kills about 30 000 people a year in the
U.S so we've known for a long time that
proton pump inhibitors are a major risk
factor for C diff we know proton pump
inhibitors are a major risk factor for
campylobacter jajuni very common
foodborne infection and other enteric
illnesses that affect the GI tract so in
the GI World it really shouldn't have
been a surprise but I think the numbers
were still pretty astounding that it
could increase the risk that much and
you know for people on ppis there there
are people who have serious indications
but again a lot of the people who are on
ppis can probably get off them or take a
lower dose or use an antacid something
that you use sporadically so an antacid
that you take only when you're having
active reflux as opposed to a PPI that
you take every day and you know having a
really sort of Frank conversation with
your prescriber about what your
indication is for this drug and whether
you really need it and then coming up
with a plan for how to taper off which
you will find in the book yeah I mean
there's a difference between somebody
who has some kind of chronic
um acid reflux issue versus the
individual who has a terrible diet and
is creating that as a result of
lifestyle choices and wants to go on the
PPI so they can continue to perpetuate
the bad habit right so it's driving
multiple negative outcomes because it's
allowing you to continue to do something
that your body is trying to tell you you
shouldn't be doing right your stomach pH
is what it is for a reason it's not just
so that it can optimally digest your
food it is this line of defense for
these other pathogens and when you
change that pH obviously you're
weakening your body's ability to do what
it's naturally you know there to do and
that's why we see so many manifestations
of long-term PPI use in different parts
of the body we see an increased risk for
dementia we see kidney disease we see an
increased fracture risk because it's
it's affecting and disrupting the
delivery of nutrients to all these
different parts of the body but the mark
kidding is so fascinating and I remember
reading this terrific book a long time
ago before I ever wrote a book called
our daily Meds by Melody Peterson she's
a Believer a medical journalist maybe
for the New York Times
and she described in that book The
Campaign around acid block or drugs so I
think so many people out there believe
that they have overproduction of stomach
acid
overproduction of stomach acid is an
exceedingly rare condition called
Zollinger Ellison syndrome that occurs
in about one in a million people in the
U.S so that means there may be 350 close
to 400 people in the U.S who actually
have overproduction of stomach acid for
everybody else who has reflux what they
have is inappropriate relaxation of that
sphincter that valve between the
esophagus and the stomach that's
supposed to shut tight to keep the
stomach contents in the stomach so we
have inappropriate relaxation opening
and then the acid comes up but it's not
overproduction
and so if you start to believe you know
if the marketing is around
overproduction you think oh I have too
much stomach acid and the marketing is
around stomach acid being bad then it's
an easy step to then say oh yeah let me
block my stomach acid and I'll be better
off but if you really understand that
it's that inappropriate opening of the
valve and what opens it in appropriately
eating late at night after the stomach
is basically shut down and gone to sleep
because it follows the Circadian rhythm
so eating a large meal late at night
overfilling it stomach's about the size
of your fist eating food with a high fat
high protein content like a lot of
animal protein which will slow down
emptying of the stomach caffeine alcohol
chocolate all of that stuff so when you
understand what's going on and you think
okay
I can do some stuff here I can eat a
little bit earlier I can eat a smaller
meal I can eat my big meal earlier I can
cut down on my Dairy and alcohol and
caffeine you start to understand how you
can affect that as opposed to doing this
incredibly drastic and potentially
disastrous thing which is to completely
shut down your acid pump
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but I want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised I'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner are affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition Excellence by
providing access to thousands of Highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering ten dollars
off an annual membership when you use
the promo code rrhealth at checkout this
is life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
mealss.richeral.com promo code rrhealth
for ten dollars off an annual membership
all right
let's get back to the show well
continuing on this I suppose the lane
that we're in right now is the impact of
pharmaceuticals on gut dysregulation and
in turn immune system dysfunction we're
all fairly familiar I think at this
point with the Havoc that antibiotics
can wreak on this system so I don't know
that we need to explore that any further
sort of self-evident but but there's
some other things here that you talk
about in the book that I was I also
didn't fully appreciate
um one of them being NSAIDs basically
you know non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs the the motrins and the Advils
yeah so I've always thought of those
being relatively benign well as an
athlete you've probably relied on them a
lot too right and I'll just tell you my
little story about these drugs I um as a
gastroenterologist when I used to take
call in the hospital
pretty much at least once a month we
would see somebody with near fatal
bleeding from taking a non-steroidal one
too many doses and you don't need a lot
on like Tylenol acetaminophen where to
get liver injury from Tylenol there's a
set dose amount that you have to exceed
NSAIDs aren't as forgiving so you can
take you know 800 milligrams of Motrin
which isn't that much and end up with a
huge ulcer if the area that ulcerated
happened to be over a major blood vessel
you can potentially bleed to death and
so literally at least once a month we
would see somebody with massive you know
near fatal bleeding from an ulcer in the
wrong spot that was created by NSAIDs
and um you know so as a result of that
I'm very wary of taking those drugs the
only time I take them I usually would
take them at around mile 20 of a
marathon yeah I'm a slow but steady
marathoner but the knees aren't what
they used to be so usually around mile
20 when it's just you know feels like
bone grating on bone
I would take some and typically at the
end of the race I would be vomiting and
you know people like oh you really ran
hard I'm like no it's the NSAID they
really affect me so I get really
nauseated but again like the ppis these
drugs work really well in 2017 I tore my
MCL
snowboarding and couldn't was out in
Utah couldn't straighten the leg was in
a lot of pain difficult to fly back
and my husband was like just take some
of this like why are you in pain
took away the pain I mean it was like
magic and maybe I shouldn't be surprised
I'm a doctor but I generally don't take
these drugs it was incredible how well
this drug worked to take away the pain
so you can understand for people who
have chronic injuries or in chronic pain
who have inflammatory conditions
it's understandable how you can take the
drug and become dependent on it but it's
really important to understand what's
the price you're paying on the flip side
so we talked about those ulcers
NSAIDs make tiny little holes in your
gut lining that can sometimes be bigger
whole so we call erosions or can be
really big holes that we call ulcers so
that's what those are and when we do
endoscopy or a technique called a video
capsule endoscopy Little Pill Cam that
you swallow that takes pictures through
the GI tract when we do that in
asymptomatic people taking NSAIDs we see
a very high percentage rate we see in
some studies up to 30 percent of people
having these erosions these little holes
in the gut and so it's important for
people to also understand that it's not
just if you're symptomatic like me
you're nauseated you're vomiting because
you took too much Motrin and you feel
really sick you can be asymptomatic and
still have this and again they're people
who need to take these drugs or people
with severe arthritis where these drugs
are the only thing that keep them
functional so that they can move without
pain but there is definitely a flip side
to that and so the Integrity of the gut
lining
is really again we talked about stomach
acid the gut lining is another one of
those really really important barriers
it is physically literally a barrier to
keep the virus from getting in and
penetrating getting into the bloodstream
traveling to different parts of the body
wreaking havoc in the body and what we
see is that these NSAIDs end up creating
breaches increasing the intestinal
permeability and making you more
susceptible right so this is leaky gut
this is essentially leaky gut is one of
those again ephemeral ethereal terms
that you know people understand a lot of
different things by it but I remind
people that what we're talking about
when we say leaky gut is an increase in
intestinal permeability and that's a
mechanism more than a necessarily an
actual disease right it is it is a
mechanism and other things can do it you
know intense exercise can increase
intestinal permeability temporarily I
mean it would be an interest steady for
you after a really long run or bike ride
to check your intestinal permeability
before and after there's some tests you
can do and see but it comes back to
normal so that's a physiological
response but what we're talking about
and I think what's generally understood
when people say leaky gut is a
persistent increase in the permeability
that allows things that normally
shouldn't to go through that gut lining
and enter the body and be disseminated
different parts of the body and cause
responses right so in other words
viruses can then leak through that
membrane and find their way into your
tissues and create disease absolutely
right so that's the relationship between
the the the gut issue and the immune
system issue
that's it and that level yeah
um what about birth control pills and
other forms of hormone therapy yeah
hormonal therapy can affect the balance
of gut bacteria you know there was a
study done published in the journal
Nature a few years ago and as you said
we all know about antibiotics and most
of us are pretty familiar with the
damage that proton pump inhibitors do
and that change in acid also changes a
gradient of gut bacteria it interrupts
that and so long-term ppis can have the
same effect if not worse than
antibiotics on dysbiosis but this this
article in nature looked at about 42
different classes of drugs and they it
was a wide variety of drugs that are
causing dysbiosis so for example the
ssris that people antidepressants
that people use can be Associated drugs
like Prozac
there's associations with Prozac causing
resistant E coli I think about all the
young women I see with you know sort of
recurrent urinary tract infections who
may be taking fluoxetine Prozac so
they're all these drug interactions and
hormonal therapy is another one and
again not suggesting that these drugs
are bad I am thrilled that we have all
of these medications in our Arsenal but
I'm a really firm believer and a strong
advocate for more judicious use and for
people really understanding the risks
right that nothing is free there is
always a flip side with a pharmaceutical
intervention and they need to understand
the risk and really personalize that
based on what their risk factors are so
for hormonal therapy if you are somebody
for example with a strong history family
history if you're menopausal woman and
you have a strong family history or
personal history of breast cancer or
endometrial cancer
you might consider that differently
versus if you're somebody with a history
of heart disease and what goes into that
but the idea that you know every
post-menopausal woman should be on
hormonal replacement therapy or every
young woman should be on birth control
and you know the birth control is one I
really struggle with because we know
that unwanted pregnancies is something
that keeps woman and particularly young
woman and young women of color
in poverty
and so birth control has revolutionized
the ability of young women to have
control over their lives and prevent
unwanted pregnancies and so on but it's
at the same time it's important to
acknowledge that there is a downside for
some people right and that it does
potentially have an effect on the
microbiome not so much birth control
just on its own but then if you add in
this is somebody who's taken a lot of
antibiotics this is somebody who's been
on steroids this is somebody who's eaten
a highly processed diet this is you know
it it's one of those factors to take
into account as opposed to just you know
nobody should be on it or everybody
should be on it so this more
personalized approach and understanding
your own medical history and risk
stratification and then putting that in
the context of the pharmaceutical is is
really important yeah beautifully put I
mean this is certainly not my intention
is not to villainize any any medication
but I think it is so important to
understand the comprehensive nature of
what's going on when you ingest certain
things I think that we have this limited
or you know back to this idea of of
being overly dualistic about things like
I'm taking this thing for this single
purpose but there's a Cascade of
ramifications to that and not the least
of which is how it's impacting our
microbiome and I think it's you know I
can't say that when I take a medication
I think
uh what is this doing in my microbiome
like that's not the first thing that
comes well now after I will now I should
you know I don't really take medications
anyway but uh I mean you know unless I'm
dealing with something acute uh but to
understand that we have to think about
these things in in a you know from a
holistic perspective that you know it's
not just about like you see the ad for
the farm the pharmaceutical on TV and
it's you know they they rapid fire
through all that terrible side effects
but you know I I don't know that I've
ever heard anyone say you know might
lead to microbiome just you know
dysbiosis it should though right don't
you think yeah I mean a perfect example
of that is cough syrup and that was one
I have to say the mucus section in the
book yeah let's talk about mucus geeked
out on because I you know been talking
about gut bacteria and dysbiosis and
acid blockers for a long time but mucus
was sort of a new area for me and a lot
of people think of mucus as something
that you know it comes from your head or
your lungs but the majority of mucus is
made in your gut we make about one and a
half liters of mucus a day
and mucus serves some really important
purposes so it lubricates the gut
obviously as the products of digestion
come through it provides a protective
layer for that razor thin intestinal
lining I talked about and in the stomach
it helps the stomach from being Auto
digested by all the acid that's being
produced so mucus is really important
but the role is much more than just a
lubricant it's just it's this cross
somebody I forget who it was described
it as a cross between Jello and glue
and it's a sticky Matrix that ensnares
things and then the Cilia the little
finger-like projections in the lungs
move it all up and you cough it out or
you swallow it and if you swallow it and
you have stomach acid then the stomach
acid denatures a protein and does its
thing
if you suppress mucus
you know you have a runny nose I mean
when you have a runny nose it's because
your body is producing more mucus to
fight something that you're dealing with
whether that's a seasonal allergy or an
infection because mucus traps pollen and
irritants and smoke and other things too
to expel it from your body
so you have a runny nose you take a
cough suppressant or some sort of
antihistamine or something to dry up
your mucus
and now one of your main defense is the
ability of the mucus to trap and expel
is gone right and so now it's gonna it's
gonna stick around and maybe get down
into your lungs and what's really
incredible speaking of pharmaceuticals
you look back at things like Mrs
Winslow's soothing syrup and the
original Bayer formulation for cough
syrup this stuff had heroin and morphine
in it right so it was it really made
your kids stop coughing right maybe they
didn't wake up I mean it was incredible
and really for some of these ingredients
it wasn't until the 1970s that some of
this stuff was taken out and so the
American Association of American Academy
of Pediatrics now recommends that you
don't use these cough expectorants or
anti-spectorans in kids but this
shouldn't be used in adults either and
again like you have a hacking cough
you're trying to get relief you're you
know keeping your partner up but again
it comes at a cost so what are some
other things that you can do right to
think about to help with this as opposed
to blocking this really important host
defense and the mucus also provides a
layer
you know in the book I talk about it's I
don't know anything about football but I
used a football analogy it's equivalent
of like going through 150 football
fields to make a touchdown or something
just for the distance when you add that
mucous layer on top of the lining it
creates this protective layer that the
viruses have to Wade through to
penetrate the gut lining so serves these
really important purposes and then
there's also the whole concept of mucins
in mucus which are the proteins in mucus
that degrade enzymes so just like
stomach acid can denature viral protein
mucins and mucus an enzyme that can
degrade protein and depending on the
composition of your mucins and how
healthy they are you can be the kind of
person where the virus gets in the
mucins in your mucus immediately
degraded and you're good versus your
mucus isn't that good and it sticks
around and this has a lot to do with the
whole concept of super spreaders right
so we know that for a lot of the viral
illnesses from measles for Ebola for
SARS cov2 it's often a small group of
people who are disseminating the virus
widely
and so if you connect super spreading to
mucus if you happen to get coughed on by
somebody who has SARS cov2 but who has
really good mucus that has broken down
degraded the virus you're not going to
get infected but if you get coughed on
by somebody whose mucus is not so hot
they're more likely to spread it to you
so you have super spreaders and you have
super recipients based on you know if
you have really healthy mucus you're
going to be protected versus not so the
cool thing to me is like this is all
stuff we can work on you know we can
hydrate to improve the quality of our
mucus
we cannot smoke if we're smokers we can
think about the quality of our external
environment there are lots of things
that go into it and a really fascinating
aside about mucus is with pregnancy the
cervical mucus the thickness of it tells
us a lot about what's going on so that's
something that Obstetricians have done
for years during labor they will examine
are sort of leading up to labor they'll
do a manual exam and they'll tell the
thickness and they can feel it with
their hands and if the mucus is really
thin and watery they know that that
person is at risk for preterm infection
because the mucus isn't thick enough to
to prevent pathogens from getting in and
they may do something differently so you
know it's it's mucus not just in the GI
tract but also cervical mucus we can
tell different stages of ovulation based
on what the mucus feels like and
fertility
it's really that's super fascinating
yeah I mean I I didn't realize the the
diversity of mucus I mean I always
understood it to be a protective you
know system in our body that can
neutralize diseases but you know it's
also something that we've kind of been
conditioned to fear because disease
spreads through droplets and you know on
the subject of super spreaders you're in
a you know an enclosed environment with
a lot of people and somebody sneezes or
coughs or you know mucus is is shared
communally like that's something to be
terrified about right
um but to the extent that some people's
mucus is benign or safe versus the
person who has the subpar mucus that can
in turn be you know an accelerant to the
spread of disease is fascinating so
first of all I mean the obvious question
is like how do you know if your mucus is
doing its job and what are the things
that you can do to ensure that your you
know mucus this is Tip Top I mean
hydration uh is it like you know
humidifying your room yeah a diet plays
a huge role and the humidifying may help
if you're congested I think the thing
about you know you mentioned about being
terrified to me because other people's
mucus isn't as cool as your own mucus
it's kind of like other people's yeah I
don't know right my stool is good that's
fine I'm sure it's good you know I don't
need it it is um there there are lots of
tips you know one of the things that the
um my team at Avery who I've been with
them for all the books from they took a
chance on me in
2013 with God bless all the way through
is they've really encouraged me to
provide more actionable information
because I'm like oh this is great I'm
going to tell people all about this and
like that's good to know but what can I
do what am I supposed to do and to
really to so with this it went from
being like a kind of little side thing
with got this microbrime solution had a
bigger plan with this one it's a third
of the book it's page count wise it
might even be closer to a half and to
really really you know think deeply
about so if we think about fever
something we haven't gotten into yet
what are the guidelines and really you
know pulling those guidelines about when
to treat a fever when not what else can
you do medication section if you're not
taking an NSAID what else could you take
and here are some questions to ask your
doctor what about every other day dosing
what about these kinds of NSAIDs that
are not as disruptive to the GI tract
whatever so really trying to feel a
little more prescriptive for people as
opposed to just you know don't do this
right well let's talk about fever and
heat because this is another thing it's
like oh I have an ache I'll take uh you
know I'll take an Advil oh you know I'm
feeling flemmy I'll take a cough
suppress these are all very you know
knee-jerk common reactions to ailments
that we've all experienced and on that
note you know the idea that when you
have a fever oh we need to bring the
fever down like this is not good right
so walk us through
the protective mechanism of the fever
and what it's doing to us and when it is
appropriate to try to lower it and when
we should just let it run its course and
I'll tell you fever is one of those
things that was good then bad and maybe
getting good again so this idea of you
know you think about different cultures
and things like sweat lodges and saunas
Etc that's all thermal therapy that's
all heat therapy and Hippocrates I mean
everybody's familiar with the all
disease begins in the gut but
Hippocrates also famously said give me a
fever and I can cure any illness and I
think it was in 1927 an Austrian
physician won the Nobel Prize for heat
therapy that was being used to treat
neurosyphilis so that successfully I
mean of course we have we have drugs now
that are more effective but so heat
therapy and this idea of fever as being
therapeutic is not something new we're
seeing now thermal therapy and cancer
finding that using heat to treat can
cancer cells to kill them is effective
poliovirus replicates 250 times faster
at normal body temperature compared to
with a fever
so fever is a really important defense
your body has of slowing down if not
halting viral replication
and what's the first thing we do when we
have a virus and a fever as we reach for
an antipyretic something to stop the
fever so understanding that fever is our
body's sign that there's something going
on and also our body's therapeutic
response to try and handle that thing
whatever it is that's going on so just
the replication rates and so in the book
I do talk about when it's okay to take
an antibiotic or maybe if you can even
wait a little bit and then take it allow
your body time to try and you know get
its antiviral
fever virus you know slowing down
replication processes going but there's
uh there's really interesting data too
there's some my studies if we look
particularly at elderly people a lot of
the morbidity and mortality around covid
with elderly people is this condition
ards acute respiratory distress syndrome
which is essentially lung failure
and studies in mice show that at high
heat for a few hours
we don't see the respiratory cells dying
the same way and then you think about
the fact that elderly people often are
not able to mount a high febrile
response right kids can get their
temperature up to 105 106 but older
people not so much and so they're
looking experimentally now at whether
thermal therapy might be a treatment for
ards I mean this hasn't gone into the
human stage yet but they've seen it in
mice for slowing down the um the death
of the respiratory cells and then again
in the uh we've seen similar thermal
therapy happening in the cancer world so
again we have to be thoughtful about
this we have to understand the process
you know what is our body trying to do
and make sure that we're not sabotaging
that process in our efforts to feel
better and there are plenty of things
you can do to feel better when you have
a fever that can do that and make you
more comfortable without sabotaging that
process and also understanding for our
kids you know it's not just a
temperature it's what else is happening
with your kid is your kid listless not
eating not making eye contact especially
with babies that's a more worrisome sign
the kid might have a fever of 104 but
it's running around eating playing
laughing that's a whole different matter
so what else do you look at and how do
you you know how do you make this
evaluation obviously this should be done
in concert with with people's Healthcare
practitioner but giving people some
basic information about that and some
questions to ask yeah well obviously if
you have an elevated body temperature
and that's slowing replication rates of
the acute viral infection that you're
trying to combat you want to allow that
to take place but I would presume that
there are other physiological systems
that get disrupted by an elevated body
temperature and at some point when that
threshold that temperature threshold
exceeds a certain set level it becomes
problematic and you do want to bring it
down that's right and and again it's not
just the number it's what else is going
on but I'll tell you
um and that's why it's important to have
that done in an actual medical setting
and not just rely on you know what I'm
putting out in my book a couple other
things in terms of the gut fever
connection so when you have a fever
slows down viral replication it also
recruits additional immune cells for the
immune response and can enhance
production of certain antiviral
cytokines and interestingly in the gut
it helps to tighten up those Junctions
so those connections between cells we
talked about intestinal permeability the
tight junctions when you have a fever
the tight junctions realize oh we're
battling something here we need to
tighten up our battalions our forces
here and the Junctions become Tighter
and the gut membrane becomes less
permeable to whatever virus bacteria Etc
you're fighting so
it's fascinating how it affects you know
your immune system your gut all the
different things that are going on when
you have a fever super interesting did
you look at any of the research or
science that's coming out on sauna
therapy not in the context of combating
an infection but just as a daily
practice in terms of what it's doing to
us
benefits negatives I haven't rich but
I'm a huge sauna fan anything hot
um I do heated Vinyasa Flow Yoga I love
saunas I I feel like heat and you know
you could hearken back to ayurveda and
talk about Pita Vata and you know maybe
do some analysis there but um it
certainly feels good in my body what
what give me a little update well I just
think I mean I'm certainly no expert on
this but I know there's there's some
indications that it perhaps might be a
longevity extender
um and you know certainly you know as an
athlete in terms of recovery and all
these other kind of things there seems
to be some interesting uh signs coming
out to support that but then the next
thing I wanted to ask you is you know
cold exposure like ice baths because
this is all the thing now and I've been
playing around with like the sauna and
the ice bath and going back and forth is
there anything that you learned about
cold therapy yeah you know these
extremes so and this is really connected
to the idea of stress and really
important hair to distinguish between
acute stress and chronic stress so these
these acute stressors
cold
fasting running long distances Heat
tend to all be moving Us in the right
direction I mean depending on how it's
done and what your Baseline is but these
are all things that have been associated
with longevity and with
um you know improving Health in
different studies again depending on the
context
with acute stress you are actually
recruiting additional immune cells and
you're strengthening that response but
it's the chronic stress so you want that
fight or flight for short brief periods
of time and you want it to be able to
you know escape the lion or the snake or
whatever it is that's about to attack
you but you don't want that revved up
immune system
over long periods of time
because then that becomes
a problem and that becomes a threat to
your health so I don't know it would be
really interesting to look and I don't
know
um the the sort of intermittent exposure
to cold therapy and cryotherapy versus a
sustained cold response what you know
whether that moves you from a realm of
acute stress to chronic stress and how
that works but certainly little touches
of that are
I mean I could tell you that that it's
definitely a mood elevator and it's
certainly
um an anti-inflammatory like it's
helpful in recovering from exercise
induced stress and I just feel better in
my body like I just I know it's a good
thing like I just you know I'm
interested in the science that supports
that well there's definitely a lot of it
out there where I'm from Jamaica
originally as you know and we would sum
it up by saying a little sufferation is
a good thing a little separation I think
that's the title of this podcast you
just kind of what I'm going to title it
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with them
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
let's talk a little bit about food and
diet I mean this is something we've
explored extensively also in past
episodes so I don't want to linger too
long here we all know we need to
increase the amount of fiber in our diet
there's this rule of thumb 30 different
plants a week basically but there were
some other things in in in your book
that were a little bit new to me not the
least of which was this emphasis on not
just fiber but short chain fatty acids
specifically in inulin so talk a little
bit about that yeah so
you know there's there are very few bad
plans of what's edible right poisonous
stuff isn't good and I'm I'm not a huge
fan of creating these hierarchies you
know white potato bad sweet potato good
Etc
um most of us I would add to Michael
pollan's fantastic book in defense of
food you know he has that little thing
on the cover that says eat food not too
much mostly plants I would add to that
eat more vegetables you know the numbers
are just astounding something less than
five percent of Americans are getting
the recommended grains and greens Etc so
we all need more vegetables even many of
my completely plant-based patients are
eating a lot of processed plants need to
eat more vegetables but there are
some in particular that really have a
pronounced effect on the levels of short
chain fatty acids and so when you look
at something like inulin that you can
get from rolled oats and from onion and
garlic and leeks Etc what we find is
that kind of fiber it's sort of that
stringy fiber hard fiber
is the preferred food of bacteria like
the fecalobacterium presnet CI in terms
of the fermentation process creating
short chain fatty acids like butyrate
propionate Etc and these short chain
fatty acids help to regulate the immune
system so they help to prevent that
overblown response but they also act
locally
on the immune system so it's not just
sort of acting in a more General
managerial way but on the local immune
response so for example they can down
regulate the number of viral receptors
in tissue sufficient levels of short
chain fatty acids so we've known for a
long time they've been some Landmark
studies Paula leonetti study from
gosh that study must have been early
2000 maybe no maybe 2012 or so from
about 10 years ago where he looked at
kids in Burkina Faso and compared them
to kids from Florence Italy and you know
the kids eating the Florentine diet
we're eating kind of a standard American
diet because it had become Western it
was no longer a medicine it's not a
Mediterranean diet anymore yeah and um
and the the baby the groups of of babies
were similar at Birth these were for
vaginally born breastfed babies but once
they sort of graduated to table food
everything changed and the kids in
burtina FASA were eating uh essentially
almost 100 plant-based diet except I
think they were eating some termites in
the rainy season and a free-range
chicken here and there versus the kids
in in Florence were eating a lot of
animal protein fat sugar Etc the
microbiomes are vastly different and one
of the biggest differences was the
levels of short chain fatty acids the
kids from Burkina Faso had more than
double the levels of short chain fatty
acids and the fascinating thing about
this study which is that neither group
of kids were sick we're talking about
infants these are healthy infants but
you could already see the foundation for
disease for susceptibility to viral
illness being laid down in the
microbiome and again to your point this
is not host Health matters and it
matters early on too I mean of course
there are other fantastic studies that
show you can change a stuff within a
short period of time but you know this
this Foundation that we're building is
really important and I really focus with
my patients on what you're missing more
than what you're eating you know you're
eating pizza so you know know we can
deal with that but you're missing the
kind of fiber that fibrous fiber that is
going to lead to production of short
chain fatty acids that is going to keep
you healthy and so really focusing on
adding and I mean it can literally be
adding in a stock of celery
and those short chain fatty acids really
help to patch any of these holes that
are leading to leaky gut right
absolutely that is sort of like the cure
to that or the fix strongly correlated
with
sort of more normal intestinal
permeability yeah so what say you to the
carnivore diet Enthusiast who is telling
you that all this nonsense about fiber
is overblown and I've been eating
nothing but steak for the last year and
I feel fantastic well you know I think
it's important for people to understand
the concept of statistics and we were
talking about this earlier like we all
know people who've smoked two packs of
Marlboros for 90 years and are fine but
does that mean that cigarettes do not
increase your risk for lung cancer of
course not so you know we have to rely
on the population based data that we
have which is very robust and we know
that fiber is a main ingredient for
creating a healthy microbiome fiber and
fermented food that's that's really not
up for debate now does it mean that
there's not room for animal protein on
the plate no it doesn't necessarily mean
that there are other reasons to avoid
animal protein there environmentally
reasons and ethical reasons Etc but from
a medical lens it is it's making sure
that there's sufficient amounts of
indigestible plant fiber on the plate
that is really the most important
element of that and then the issue about
whether you're going to eat meat or not
again that's a more personalized
individualized issue and lots of other
factors go into that but there's no
debate about the fiber and and it
doesn't mean that you of course you
could be a carnivore your whole life and
somehow manage to be fine but you're an
N equal one number that does not a
scientific study make right so the
low-hanging fruit in terms of things to
avoid uh would would
include artificial sweeteners sugar
fatty foods alcohol processed foods
we're all you know this is all like
Common Sense stuff right but I loved the
example that you gave of your patient
called Alicia because I feel like that
really Illustrated
um the interplay between all of these
things and and how challenging and
difficult it can be to diagnose somebody
who's coming in to you with you know
some sense of something being awry and
the process of like trying to figure out
how to untangle that knot
can you tell that that story yes
it was a one who was obsessed about
fungal organisms and I see this a lot in
my practice because again there's you
know there's all this
hype around different things right so
overgrowth of fungal organisms and you
have candida overgrowth and that's
what's causing all your problems and
it's really balance so we need yeast in
our microbiome yeast play a really
critical role in part of the digestive
process but we don't want too much yeast
and so when you kill off a lot of the
healthy bacteria with an antibiotic you
leave more room in there and you can get
overgrowth of fungal organisms but she
had been eating a super restrictive diet
essentially no carbohydrates and
um you know she's eating a occasional
little bit of vegetable green vegetable
no fruit no grains tons of meat she'd
taken these really potent antifungals
that I was really concerned about her
liver and reminding her that the healthy
food the food for our healthy gut
bacteria are carbohydrates it's not meat
that
is eating carbohydrates yeah and that
carbohydrates make you fat and you know
you see the studies coming out all the
time showing that a primarily
plant-based diet Whole Foods plant-based
diet is the not just for overall health
not just for resiliency to viruses but
also for weight but people somehow have
gotten so stuck on this idea that
carbohydrates are bad and you know we
need carbohydrates are
incredibly important fuel for the gut
not just to grow a good gut Garden in
terms of gut Flora but also for
providing bulk in the stools so that
things can move along and you I see
these patients coming in on these
ketogenic diets incredibly constipated
yeah that's a common thing yeah right
let's talk about sleep some of the
statistics in the Sleep section of the
book are like mind-blowing uh like what
happens in our gut when we're sleep
deprived the risk of viral infection
skyrockets 88 percent
is that crazy the sleep I have to say
when I turned in the first draft of this
book The Sleep chapter was 60 pages
and the folks that Avery were like um
Matthew Walker you're not Matthew Walker
yeah Sean Stevenson wrote that book like
that they're really good sleep books out
there
but it was so fascinating rich and you
know when you think about it you can go
without food a week and you will be
hangry but you can go without food for a
week you can go without water for a week
and your kidneys will start to shut down
but you'll rehydrate and you'll probably
be okay you go without sleep for a week
you will be very close to dead you will
you know your testosterone levels will
drop your risk for cardiac disease will
triple
all kinds of things will go wrong in
your body without sleep so really you
know the elixir
sleep is really essential and the Sleep
gut connection is something that is also
really profound serotonin which many
people know is a feel-good hormone is
made primarily in our gut about
somewhere between 70 and 90 depending on
which study you read of Serotonin is
produced in our gut primarily by our gut
bacteria well serotonin is a precursor
to melatonin the sleep hormone and so if
your gut bacteria are off and you have a
messed up gut and your serotonin
production is down which is a real thing
we see and that's why there's such a
correlation between gut disorders and
psychiatric disorders and mental health
so if your serotonin is off your
melatonin is going to be off and your
sleep is going to be affected and vice
versa if you're not sleeping well that's
also going to throw off what's going on
with your gut bacteria so one of the
things I see for example
is with my college student patients
they're always sick around exams when
they're not sleeping and for a lot of my
patients with crohn's disease and
ulcerative colitis with complex
autoimmune diseases they'll tell me that
sleep is a thing that totally if the
sleep is off they'll have a flare more
than anything else more than their diet
more than stress more than anything else
is really the sleep less than four hours
of sleep
correlates to a seven percent
drop in critical no set I think it was
70 percent drop in critical immune cells
the next day so this happens very
quickly it's the reason why I'm not
taking the red eye back tomorrow I'm
done tomorrow afternoon too late to
catch the 4 45 to get back to DC
but in time for the red eye but I know I
won't sleep and I'm like no I'll take
the 7 55 in the morning I am not risking
that there's crazy data about sleep and
vaccines too so if you are sleep
deprived before your vaccine
the effectiveness is significantly
reduced and and our daughter who's a
rower when she was getting her first
vaccine it was during the Regatta season
and she had to get up at like 4am or
something I figured where we were in
Philly or but we're just going somewhere
the next day and I'm like nope we got to
reschedule that there's no way you're
getting a vaccine after you know four
and a half hours sleep and so there's
really clear data not just in older
people but in everyone that being sleep
deprived in the 48 hours before you get
a vaccine
can lead to a decrease in Effectiveness
and some Studies by as much as 30
percent and that's not just for the
covet vaccine that's also for hepatitis
vaccines for flu shots Etc and you know
it's just not something that I think is
even in our awareness this idea that it
would matter we just think you get the
vaccine it works but this is one of
these factors and when you when you look
at some of the statistics in the book
that you just read the drop in immune
function when you're sleep deprived you
really start to see how it's all
connected yeah it's unbelievable the
other one that hit me really hard was
every hour that you sleep is associated
with 12 percent a twelve percent
reduction in the odds of becoming that's
right by a viral infection
I mean infected means how are you
defining that because exposure meaning
becoming ill yeah becoming ill but you
know I think we we can all think about
times in our life when we've been you
know for me it was every year before a
big gi conference Digestive Disease week
which happens in May and typically
especially when I was still full-time at
the hospital at Georgetown and so be
working on five or six different
presentations and you know it's like you
know this stuff is coming six months in
advance but it's still last minute
you're getting slides together and
you're you know finishing stuff up and
not sleeping and invariably I'd get sick
and you know as I said I see it with my
college students who have chronic
autoimmune diseases you see it you're
you're run down and you're more likely
to get sick and we know that sort of in
the back of our minds intellectually
right but when you run down you're tired
you're not sleeping well you're more
likely to get sick but I think we're not
aware how profound
that impact is and I think I think
Matthew Walker when he was on
talked about this incredible Global
study right with daylight savings time
and how we see this tremendous increase
I think up to a 25 24 25 increase in
heart attacks the day after we all lose
an hour of sleep and then a drop not as
dramatic but significant yeah and then
when you think about residents med
school residents working these insane
shifts in hospitals where they become
more susceptible to disease and
infection then of course they're going
to be more likely to shed and spread it
right when they're doing their rounds go
into any Hospital Physician's lounge and
look at what's in there it's soda and
donuts and ham sandwiches why can't we
solve that you know um Neil Bernard and
his wonderful group of Physicians
committee for responsible medicine are
are doing a petition now they've been
helping them with the folks at
Georgetown to remove known carcinogens
from the hospital meal tray so sausage
bacon I mean You could argue about
whether you are going to serve animal
protein or not in hospitals but you
cannot make an argument for why you
would be serving sausage and bacon to
sick people in the hospital my dad had a
cardiac catheterization about
five years ago had a cute event playing
tennis and went in and had you know
state-of-the-art Care at Washington
Hospital Center incredible cardiac
services and they went right in aborted
the heart attack fantastic I was in New
Haven at a college reunion I rushed back
he's sitting there he's lying in the bed
there's a hamburger on his plate this is
what they're serving him after an acute
cardiac event you know out of the cath
lab recovered sanity insanity why is it
so difficult to solve this problem like
where is The Missing Link in resolving
this equation I think is it the money is
it government contracts it's
disassociation between
acute treatment of illness and
prevention of illness and what we have
seen rich
is that the medical community has not
done a good job on the prevention side
I think we can all agree we're really
good with the acute side right I am
thrilled that Washington Hospital Center
was available and 10 minutes away and
they did a fantastic job with my dad and
I do credit them for for that them and
his cardiologist Jack flyer for why he's
alive at 87 and doing well and eating
lots of lentils
but the prevention side we we don't do
and when you think about it
having people be ill keeps these
organizations in business now I don't
think that they're thinking about it
that way they're not like oh we hope he
goes out and has another cardiac event
not at all it's just that it's not on
their radar right they're in the
business of the acute care
and interventions and they're not in the
business of prevention and you know
we've we've seen these other industries
that have flourished health coaches and
and other people who are really focused
on that on the diet and lifestyle and I
think it's wonderful and it has arisen
out of a great need which is a fact that
we've neglected it and you know the
medical visit is fast hospital-based
medicine you don't have a long time so
we needed to have other resources
for people other places for people to go
to to learn about that yeah when you you
kind of raise the conspiracy flag of you
know the system is set up to you know
keep sick people sick because that's
where the money is getting made I think
what gets confused in that conversation
is this idea of mustache twirling you
know Executives sitting around a table
like this conspiring to you know extract
money from the you know the woe begotten
consumer it's not that it's just that
there is a certain system in place
that's very profitable and when that is
the case there are many parties that are
invested in maintaining the Integrity of
that system and it becomes more and more
difficult to make changes but to your
point
the explosion of functional Integrative
Medicine practitioners is very
heartwarming and they are serving this
need and I think it's you know cool to
see that Blossom they found a way to
make it economically viable I mean I
think that was the big impediment right
like how how are you going to be able to
make a living doing this when the system
is set up
such that you need to see you know X
many patients a day for 15 minutes each
because of the way insurance companies
have you know created the reimbursement
schedule and it's it's not just a you
know at the practitioner level in terms
of physician level but it's really
people like health coaches who are much
more Grassroots who can do the
hand-holding and the explaining and the
walking through and you know really have
that frequent interaction because you
know gastroenterologists are really good
at doing colonoscopies and endoscopies
but most gastroenterology programs even
today don't have formal training in
nutrition really significant training in
terms of you know explaining to somebody
what's the difference between gluten
intolerance and a wheat allergy and
celiac disease
and even when we know it and I think
most gastroenterologists do know that
but do we have 45 minutes to sit down
and explain the difference to somebody
who's just been diagnosed with celiac
disease
versus somebody who is just gluten
intolerant I shouldn't say just but
somebody who's gluten intolerant that
these are very separate conditions and
they require very different approaches
and so we you know I think of it as
these you know Grassroots
community-based folks who can really do
that heavy lifting I would like to see
more disease specific training for some
of the health coaches right A lot of
them have great empathy but maybe not as
much specific training in the different
areas and I think when we get that so we
have like a whole Army of you know
diabetic diabetes Educators or dysbiosis
Educators people who help people
understand gallbladder disease and what
to do so you can hold on to your
gallbladder if you have gallstones and
not have to have it removed so we start
to see more of that disease specific
training
with health coaches I think we'll we'll
really start to move the needle yeah and
and the follow-up and the accountability
that's so critical to actually getting
somebody on a better path and the
working with the medical community so
that it's not you know either or but
you're working with a health coach
health coaches attached to medical
practices like the gastroenterologist
might diagnose somebody with celiac
disease or gallstones and then they
refer to the health coach and then the
health coach does all that work with a
diet and lifestyle the Sleep the stress
of food and then there's more you know
there's more cross-pollination between
the two so that's something that I would
love to see and I think we're moving
towards it because I think consumers are
demanding it right
um let's talk about weight specifically
obesity uh I think we're all aware that
obesity uh was or you know the the
biggest co-morbidity factor that was
driving severe covid cases some of the
statistics in your book you know are
pretty
[Music]
um
are are pretty heavy 78 percent of
patients hospitalized for covid were
obese
113 percent
uh you're 113 percent more likely to be
hospitalized for covet if you were obese
but the interesting thing to me that I'd
never really considered is the extent to
which obesity becomes a public uh Health
crisis so explain that because I've
never really pondered that I tell you
that was pretty shocking to me too so if
you think about obesity what the risk is
to the individual
we know with something like kovich so
you're going to have trouble ventilating
the lungs expanding the lungs because of
the adiposity because of the pressure on
the chest if you're if you're obese so
you have issues with ventilation you
you're going to have issues with
potential complications like clotting
because
increased weight in the setting of
obesity is associated with increased
clotting factors and other inflammatory
things floating around in the
bloodstream and you're going to have an
altered immune response because adipose
tissue fatty tissue is itself
immunologically active in a negative way
and can lead to an overblown immune
response so those are all things that
can affect the individual
but in terms of what it means for
society having obesity is also
associated with prolonged viral shedding
we've seen that for influenza we've seen
it for SARS cov2 and many other viruses
you shed the virus longer
what that means if you shed the virus
longer is that there's more opportunity
potentially to infect somebody and
there's also more opportunity for the
virus to become more virulent during
that process and so from a public health
point of view if you have a population
with a large percentage of people in it
who have obesity you're potentially
going to end up with a more virulent
viral outbreak over time yeah the [ __ ]
the the shedding with influenza was 42.
longer for people who are obese so it's
not a small margin yeah that's right and
that that was stunning to me also and it
also makes me think about you know we
saw a lot of
of collective concern and people coming
together and Goodwill during this
pandemic particularly early on and so
realizing that this is a problem that we
all share that this is we we all have a
responsibility to figure out how we can
help whether it's individually or from a
policy level make sure that people who
struggle with obesity have access to
better food place safe places to
exercise stress reduction all the
different things that contribute to it
because a it's the right thing to do and
B because it it can it has a ripple
effect on the whole society
of all the comorbidities why is obesity
such a powerful one when it comes to
susceptibility to viral infection I
think Rich it's because of all the
different elements it affects so there's
a sort of mechanical anatomical issue
with the lungs and when you can't expand
your lungs you end up having collapsed
alveoli in the lungs and the bacteria
there start to produce and you end up
with secondary infection bacterial super
infection so having a bacterial
pneumonia on top of covid can be really
deadly so with obesity they're
mechanical factors they're physiological
factors they're hormonal factors they're
endocrine factors their immune factors
so it's a condition that affects
you know every aspect of our body's
physiology and I think that unlike heart
disease where okay heart disease
primarily affects Your Heart Right may
affect your circulation
um
diabetes is primarily an endocrine
disease but with obesity and of course
our risk for all of these things heart
disease cardio metabolic disease cancer
Etc are increased right I mean obesity
doesn't live in a vacuum right it's
usually associated with some other
battery of
absolutely or yeah and it's also very
strongly correlated with changes in the
microbiome we can look at uh microbial
sample and we can predict with pretty
good accuracy whether this person has
obesity or not based on the complement
of bacteria so it's strongly Associated
but I can't say that's the factor it's
the fact that it is you know affecting
and you mentioned something about
adipose tissue tissue specifically sorry
I interrupted no no worries
um something about the adipose tissue
specifically that that has a negative
impact on immune response yes the
adipose tissue can itself release more
immune cells more than you need this
whole concept of overshooting and
cytokine storm so that's another
potential complication there for people
who have obesity
um well let's talk about getting
Outdoors
exposure to Nature bathing in the biome
right this is a big part of of uh taking
care of our gut health right is our
exposure to our natural environments
um and another you know statistic that
jumped out to me from the book on this
was what they discovered in the wake of
the 1918 Spanish flu epidemic that was
fascinating so you know we look back a
hundred years more than 100 years now
and we found that this concept of the
open air factor and it's defined as a
germicidal constituent in open air that
it's basically factors in open air many
of which were not sure what they are
that are lethal to viruses and certain
pathogenic bacteria and in the Spanish
flu epidemic what they found is that
people who recovered outside had a much
lower mortality and when we look at it
in the military setting
officers were often given a hospital bed
because they were officers and the
enlisted men were put in cots outside
the hospital when the hospitals were
overflowing well the mortality was very
different in some of those studies the
officers recuperating inside had up to a
40 percent mortality and the enlisted
soldiers on the cots outside had a 13
mortality that's a massive difference
that's a massive difference and so we
see that you know if you look at the
impact of something like Forest bathing
and I the exact Japanese term escapes me
at the moment it's something
I'll mess it up but
we know from a couple different studies
that that lowers blood pressure it
decreases risk for heart disease it
increases feelings of well-being it
decreases feelings of stress Etc
but it turns out from an immune point of
view it also does some pretty amazing
things too so this open air factor is
different from just sunlight and vitamin
D sunlight and vitamin D is a thing for
sure but it's open air and so if you
can't get outside and stroll in the
woods you can open your car window I'm
going like this but it's more like this
right pressing the button rolling it
down nobody's car window opens out
anymore you can open a car window you
can open a door you can literally sit on
a window ledge and it's been it's been
striking even in my own life how much
time I spent inside during the pandemic
we're really lucky to live right on the
edge of Rock Creek Park we moved since
you were there last and we literally the
trailhead is right outside our door so
it's really easy for us to get outside
but especially with writing this book I
mean I was sitting eight hours at a
stretch sometimes on my computer looking
out through the glass at the woods and
um you know I tell you like getting
outside you feel it you you feel better
it just has this
you know
exercising outside I mean I love the gym
I go to I you know enjoy hopping on my
Peloton bike but there's something about
being outside in the woods in nature
that feels very different from mood
everything else
and it turns out that that effect is
very real this germicidal constituent
and it you know it can be tricky it was
tricking the beginning of the pandemic
when everybody was being told to stay
inside and isolate and all of that but
we were lucky in Washington to have
these beautiful outdoor spaces and
you're you're lucky here too in
California but that's something that
people really should think about
incorporating is this time outside in
nature and ideally getting a little
dirty exposure to soil microbes yeah
it's not just the air and the sunlight
it's the greater microbiome of our
external environments and the diversity
of you know whatever is growing in the
air that we're breathing right that is
that is serving our gut health
I had a funny story I had covet in
January but I had read that study a year
before and I had told my family if I get
coveted you need to put a little cot
outside on the deck for me and that's
where I'm going to isolate and just
bring my food out there and that's where
I want to recover
I quit in January a couple days after
New Year's that's not ideal the day
before a huge snowstorm and I I'm
somebody who you know as I said I like
heat I Like It Hot
so my family was like yeah about that
cot I was like yeah I mean it turns out
I had it that my husband had it the next
day my daughter so we're all able to
isolate together which was marvelous but
what I did do beginning with that next
day with a huge snowstorm was I was out
I would bundle up double mask and I
would hit the road late at night and I
was you know trying to do as many miles
as I could
breathing because one of the things I
also experienced was lying on my back
I could feel
alveolar tissue collapse and it was like
I can't lie on my back all day like this
in the bed I could feel it and starting
to get a little chest pain so I got an
incentive spirometer one of those things
they use in the hospital after you've
had surgery where you do the deep
breaths so I was doing my incentive
spirometer I was going out and walking I
mean I wasn't out trying to run a
marathon but really doing as much as I
felt able to expand the lungs and some
of those things those basic things you
know we put people in the hospital on
their backs bad things happen yeah so
some of these things that people can
think about you know if you're able and
again not to overdo it but do what you
can manage which will depend on your
Baseline of getting outside fresh air
breathing deeply all of these things are
important
from a policy perspective I presume that
the powers that be at the CDC
Etc
had some awareness of this 1918 Spanish
flu epidemic and the difference between
recuperating outside versus inside
why and how does that not get translated
into public messaging about how to best
take care of ourselves I mean we were
told to stay inside I mean I live out in
the middle of nowhere and and habitually
run Trails where if I'm out for a couple
hours maybe I see two people and there
was yellow tape like on these Trails on
the playground it was basically illegal
to go out and do exactly this thing that
has been proven to be uh beneficial as
opposed to harmful as we were told the
lack of public health messaging around
this is really astounding if you look at
something like antibiotics we clearly if
you take rotavirus infection
rotavirus infect viral infection kills
about half a million children a year
around the world serious diarrheal
illness
we know that if you take certain
proteins from bacteria and inject it
into mice with rotavirus
it halts the diarrhea and basically
they're good
and we know that kids who have been on
an antibiotic immediately before getting
a rotavirus viral infection by the way
antibiotic as you know has no activity
against a viral infection but they still
sometimes oh diarrhea they're sick they
get that's antibiotic we know that
they're five times more likely to have a
bad outcome from rotavirus
we know the same thing for covet and
other viral illnesses gut bacteria are
essential they're an essential part of
fighting these viral illnesses not just
with modulating the immune system but by
actually releasing proteins that help by
competing for binding sites with the
viruses all these different things
no messaging nothing saying don't take
an antibiotic if you have a viral
infection and and not just no messaging
we still see Physicians hospitals other
Healthcare practitioners saying well you
have covet but just in case and granted
they're definitely prescribed
antibiotics you have bacteria we've kind
of gotten past that it's been astounding
rich and of course you have to pull out
from that the people who either have a
secondary bacterial super infection or
at risk but the majority of people who
are getting slapped on antibiotics had
none of that and actually worsening this
person's likely prognosis right with the
antibiotics so things like getting
outside things like you know avoiding
unnecessary antibiotics things like
don't suppress your cough or fever I
mean these basic things and it's it's
puzzling to me
and I don't know if maybe the feeling is
if we focus on these things it will seem
like we're detracting from those but you
know that that doesn't really mean yeah
I I feel like you know they should have
trusted us a little bit more to
understand that yeah yes we need both we
need to take care of ourselves to put
ourselves in the best position to you
know basically fend off uh this illness
that we're almost undoubtedly going to
come into contact with and understanding
that not everybody is equal and there
are certain things that we can do to put
us in a better position you know if and
when that occurs and it's it's not an if
it's a win right but I don't know maybe
they felt like that would
detract from the other messaging but I
think we're going to be doing a forensic
excavation of you know what went wrong
and what went right for many years to
come and because we will inevitably face
another pandemic uh you know my hope is
that we'll have our ducks in a row a
little bit better for next time well if
you look at the statistics
um there have been over 30 different
viruses in the last 50 years for which
there is no cure real treatment so
things like hepatitis C HIV Ebola SARS
cov2 a study from Duke in 2021 looked at
the statistical likelihood of a pandemic
of the proportions we've seen with covid
happening and calculated that at two
percent per year which means for
somebody born in
2000
that's a 40 likelihood by 2020 that this
would have happened
but yet we still seem very surprised you
know and again there's precedent for all
of this and a lot of the things that we
did seem
that they weren't super Innovative and I
think it's really easy to look back with
a retrospective scope and say we didn't
do this right we didn't do that right
and there was clearly a lot of panic I
feel like we're in a less panicked mode
right now and we're able to be more
thoughtful thoughtful about maybe
stratifying People based on risk and who
needs to do what based on risk like Age
and comorbidities and you know
medication Etc and that's been good to
see and also who needs to test and who
doesn't and who needs to get boosted and
who doesn't so I think we're seeing a
lot more thoughtfulness around that and
hopefully we will be better prepared I
mean what this has really shown us is
that our Public Health System really was
was not what it needed to be and right
so hopefully everybody's re-watching the
game tape and trying to learn you know
how to do it better next time because
we're going to need that I feel like it
was a trial run listen you know it could
have been a lot worse but a lot of
people died it wasn't nothing it was you
know a very significant event in all of
our lives and plenty of people perished
and it's incumbent upon us to sit down
and figure out how to do better next
time and my sense is that smart people
are doing that I hope they are
and it's not over but but at the same
time I'm acting like yeah so we also saw
incredible
generosity and graciousness and
community
in a way I don't think I've seen before
in in that I can remember so we saw some
good things too yeah
um you mentioned uh the prescription of
antibiotics uh and you know kind of the
the
misguidedness of that in the midst of
all of this what about Pax lovit like
that's something that's being prescribed
quite a bit for covid is there a sense
of the efficacy of that is there a sense
of the downstream gut health and immune
system implications of doing a five-day
course of that I think we don't really
know yet in this sort of real life data
what the downside is but what I will say
is I think it's being prescribed a lot
outside of the guidelines for who should
get it in terms of age or somebody who
has a comorbidity that qualifies and I
think part of that is it's it's pressure
on the physician side to feel like I
need to be able to do something other
than to tell you to go home and walk a
little bit outside and eat some
vegetables right so Physicians want to
feel like we can do something actively
and there's also pressure on the
consumer side is that people want to
know they're like look we live in this
you know modern world where we can take
a heart from somebody and put it in
somebody else and do all of these things
like you must be able to do something
for me and so I think there's pressure
on both sides and
um there's clearly efficacy in certain
groups of people
but I think it is being over prescribed
and outside of the guidelines and I
think we'll have some data coming in
soon uh you know for things like this a
short exposure probably isn't going to
be problematic but it's when we see
people on longer courses or repeated
courses we'll start to have some data in
terms of you know what the potential
downside there is
last time we spoke uh it was a lot about
how to live dirty eat clean and I have
to ask like has there been any new
revelation since we last spoke about
um
the consumer products that we use like
we we've been talking about food and
pharmaceuticals and the like but what
about beauty products what about you
know our soaps and the way in which we
you know conduct our hygiene and the
clothes that we wear and the dyes that
those clothes are made with like how are
these how are you understanding
um our habits around this and some
things that we should be thinking about
since we last convened Rich goodness
it's been seven years it's a long time
what's been exciting is to see people
realizing like oh we were too clean but
what's also interesting is this idea
that now you just have to put a
probiotic in something you know
probiotic shampoo and probiotic right
you know so we've gone from oh the
anti-bacterial to now the probacterial
and the thing that I want people to
remember is that it's less about adding
something and more about not doing
something that is harmful right so
thinking about what practices can we
stop or decrease that are removing our
healthy microbes as opposed to no I'm
going to add a microbe to something so
just not washing as much is super
helpful I know I have rosacea super
sensitive skin it's under well good
control now it's not flared up in years
and I credit part of that to the fact
that I don't wash my face that much and
that really helps and the same thing you
know I have people who are suffering
from hair loss and I I'm like why are
you putting all this stuff in your hair
like you got to give your scalp and the
scalp microbes a little chance to
regenerate and so I think because we are
so product driven right we want to take
something and to do something and I'm
happy to see that we're having you know
some actually some pretty terrific
Pro bacterial products compared to all
the antibacterial you know this idea
that we're gonna we're gonna cleanse
everything away we've definitely moved
away from that and you know you look at
products like some seaweed-based
Products Company like osea that's based
here in Malibu that I think makes
fantastic products so we're seeing much
more of that and I think the barrier for
entry is lower because it's easier for
somebody to put a product out now
they're you know with platforms you
don't have to go through two or three of
the large cpg companies to do that so
we're seeing a lot of innovation
but I think the focus still should be on
again your body is producing this stuff
if you think about stuff like the oil on
your skin and in your hair your body is
producing the stuff that is custom
produced for your body's pH and your
ideal skin type
and what do we do we scrub that away and
then we put some store-bought version on
and so you know we have to we have to
think about how we can
um work in concert a little bit more
with what our body is already doing and
sort of enhancing it but not destroying
and then replacing right it's analogous
to the cough suppressant right if we're
just putting soap on our face all the
time and and removing all of those oils
those oils are there for a reason right
like why are we getting rid of them
um it seems like a good rule of thumb
although you know orthogonal to kind of
our current modern day habits and my
sister likes to point out because I've
been quoted about you know not bathing
too much and stuff and she likes to
point out like she's like that's not
everybody in the family I like to make
it every day and sometimes I'll go over
there and uh she lives nearby and I
would have like gone for a long run in
the woods and maybe done some yoga and
I'm like I don't smell bad right and
she's like yeah you don't smell as good
as you think you do so it is interesting
there are are so many companies and new
products that are coming out that are
you know sort of chemical free or more
natural and I think there's a sense like
oh more natural is better but it also
has to be efficacious some of these
products don't actually work they don't
work we're not going to use them but in
the pecking order of of you know like
the the there's The Dirty Dozen right
what are the organic so like in consumer
products like chlorinated water or
fluoride in our toothpaste or certain
kind of shampoos do you have a sense of
the most important things that we should
be paying attention to or getting rid of
the really sudsy things like the sodium
North sulfate is a problem and people
like that because they like a sud but
some of those things what they actually
do is they disrupt the skin the
Integrity of the skin and they make it
easier for pathogenic bacteria to
penetrate or they're really toxic to the
you know the the population of staph or
chronobacterium that live on the skin
that are part of the Skin's important
ecosystem and certainly things that have
a lot of alcohol in them because
remember before we had antibiotics we
had alcohol as our main antibacterial
and even now if you go to get blood
drawn they put alcohol swab to clean the
Skin So products that have a lot of
alcohol in them are also potentially
problematic for
um
for those fragile microbes I want to
touch on Long covet for a minute I feel
like this has become like a covet this
is not meant to be like a coveted
focused
conversation but because covet is the
virus that we're currently contending
with it feels like appropriate to use
that as a lens to talk about these other
things that you talk about in the book
long covet is a tricky one I feel like
we don't really know what we're dealing
with here and you have some interesting
information in the book about this about
what we know and what we don't know and
the relationship of gut health on this
quote-unquote thing we're calling long
covet
one of the things with the book
I purposefully did not put covet in the
title the book is called the antiviral
gut tackling pathogens from the inside
out and
um while covet is definitely on the
radar there's a lot in the book as you
know you've read it about other viruses
about polio about influenza Etc and when
it comes to Long covet or post-acute
sequality covet or long-haul or all the
different names we have for it
one of the things we know a lot about is
post-viral syndromes this is not the
first post viral syndrome it won't be
the last I think the problem rich is
that we weren't expecting it because we
were thinking this is kind of like a bad
flu virus and post viral syndrome from
flu are not as common but think about
AIDS AIDS is a chronic form
of HIV HIV
the human immunode deficiency virus
causes
AIDS and it causes us prolonged disease
now we have pretty good antiretrovirals
for that but it's still a chronic
condition you think about hepatitis C
can cause cirrhosis of the liver and
liver cancer in many patients you think
about Epstein-Barr virus causes mono
it's been linked to chronic fatigue
syndrome
and has been linked to Ms now multiple
sclerosis and it's linked to certain
forms of lymphoma so we have lots of
precedent in my world in
gastroenterology we see something called
post-infectious irritable bowel syndrome
post-infectious IBS which is people who
have had a clear
infectious episode and then lo and
behold you know maybe they have acute
symptoms diary or something nausea
vomiting and those acute symptoms
resolve but then lo and behold they have
irritable bowel syndrome and the GI
tract is sort of never the same so we
have a lot of experience with if you
think about some of the sexually
transmitted diseases like herpes and
human papillomavirus so HSV HPV Etc we
know they're acute and chronic forms of
those and we also know similarly who is
at risk for those chronic forms and
there are some outliers to that but we
know for example with in women with
sexually transmitted diseases that the
population of healthy lactobacillus
bacteria in the vagina that produce acid
to repel these viruses that having lower
levels can make you more susceptible to
the acute process of after exposure
becoming infected and also to The
Chronic aspects of that so post viral
syndromes are not new but because this
is a relatively new Iris we're getting
familiar with what the post-viral
landscape looks like with long covet and
there's now there are now more than 200
different symptoms that are associated
and of course
you know a lot of this is reporting
everything sort of gets put in but we
know what some of the more common
symptoms are fatigue respiratory
symptoms brain fog
Etc and if we look at that what we see
are clear microbial differences in a lot
of these patients and a lot of this we
know from the CFS me literature with
chronic fatigue syndrome that
researchers at Cornell were able to look
at the microbiome and identify people
who had
mecfs based on
what was going on microbially and we've
seen a lot of those microbial
differences we don't have a clear-cut
microbial signature yet
but we have some hints and there was a
study that was published in one of our
GI journals they followed 106 patients
with acute covid they found a very high
rate of chronic symptoms about 76
percent and in that 76 percent they
found significant microbial
abnormalities in the people the majority
of people who went on to have chronic
symptoms versus a minority who recovered
very distinct microbial patterns so it's
difficult to sort out how much of that
is caused versus effect because the
virus itself can induce dysbiosis this
wasn't something we talked about but The
Binding of SARS cov2 to those ace2
receptors can induce microbial changes
dysbiotic microbial changes and then of
course dysbiosis itself as we've been
talking about is a risk factor for you
know having worse outcomes so you know
they're both sides to that
we know that autoimmunity is an issue we
see autoimmune markers many of those
patients never had an actual autoimmune
disease before and they still don't have
an autoimmune disease but it's almost
like a a precursor and we don't know
what's going to happen with some of
those patients with the positive anas
and different non-specific markers of
inflammation
are they going to progress to an
autoimmune disease or is that stage
where they are where they have an
autoimmune marker but not an actual
autoimmune disease a specific disease in
an unto itself we see
um EBV plays a role also yeah that was
the thing that jumped out to me that it
could there's a there's a sense that it
might be a reactivation of a virus and
and I didn't realize that like a huge
percentage of people are harboring some
you know amount of that virus the
majority of the population and EBV is
fascinating the history because if we
look at you know 100 years ago
um they called it
idiopathic adenitis I mean idiopathic
meaning unknown adenitis means the the
glands are inflamed and then it was
until researchers at Hopkins you know a
couple decades later linked this to Mono
and then just recently this year some
groundbreaking breaking research linking
the EBV to Ms and the lymphoma
connection has been made a few decades
ago so it's still evolving and the role
that EBV and reactivation of EBV may
play
and non-covet is still you know there's
still a big question mark there but
again we have precedent because we have
lots of research in the MS world in the
lymphoma World Etc so for people out
there who are struggling you know I want
them to know that even though the virus
is novel The Science is not novel we
have a lot of data we have a lot of
researchers a lot we do know and there
you know there are lots of people
working on it
final thing I want to get into in into
with you before I let you go I I gotta
know where we're at with uh the fecal
transplant clinics that are supposed to
be popping up everywhere right I you
know it's when you hear about all of
these uh gut dysbiosis
um
illnesses and
the extent to which people like you can
look at the gut Flora see what's missing
see what's proliferating Etc it seems to
follow that a lot of this could be
resolved by simply culturing uh fecal
you know transplants and inserting them
in people and resolving this issue so
explain why that is too simplistic a
solution to these problems
if we look at some diseases so if we go
back to the Clostridium difficile I was
talking about Clostridium difficile
again a bacteria
lurking in many hospitals some of us are
colonized with it but at low levels you
take an antibiotic you kill off a lot of
your Healthy bacteria and now the C diff
that's either there or that you've
acquired when you went to visit your
grandpa in the hospital or if you
yourself were hospitalized is now
proliferating and you have C diff
colitis and you have this severe
diarrheal illness
a stool transplant in that setting in
the study published in the New England
Journal medicine a couple years ago they
actually had to stop the study early
because the group that received the
stool transplant did so much better than
the group that received antibiotics and
when you think about it a problem that's
caused by antibiotics the likelihood
you're going to have you know some
fantastic solution from antibiotics is
pretty low right so but fmt fecal
microbiota transplant the technical term
was shown to be vastly superior to the
antibiotic treatment Vancomycin that had
hair to 4 been the standard for this and
the reason that it works so well is
because that's an acute problem your
Healthy bacteria have been killed off by
this dose of antibiotics you've acquired
this bacteria and we're going to crowd
it out with a lot of other healthy
bacteria and it's going to take care of
the problem
when we look at more chronic problems
like autoimmune diseases like a problem
of Crohn's Disease or ulcerative colitis
or Autism or Parkinson's or a lot of
these things that we're looking at fmt
we're looking to fmt as a solution I
think the biggest problem is that the
studies have been short-term
you're not going to cure a chronic
disease giving a stool transplant for a
week or two weeks or maybe even two
months
and the other problem is we're not
looking at what we're feeding those gut
microbes so there was an Autism study
looking at fmt in conjunction with diet
over several months and that study
really stood out Head and Shoulders
above the other studies whereas fmt
alone and the same in the GI world just
a few weeks ago I was actually on
vacation in turkey and so the time you
know we were seven hours ahead from DC
and one of my GI colleagues you know
we're all geek out on this stuff texted
me and it was like three in the morning
or something about this study
um that just came out from Johns Hopkins
looking finding that clostridium
difficile infection was actually
potentially linked to colon cancer and
he's a person my colleague at Georgetown
really great guy Mark matar who does a
lot of fecal transplants and so I saw it
and then like we immediately started
this text exchange and my husband was
like it's 3 A.M in Turkey but the reason
it was so exciting for us is it links
the antibiotic use because you know why
do people get C diff the vast majority
it's from antibiotics you have some more
sporadic or community acquired but it's
primarily related to this antibiotic use
and maybe exposure in the hospital and
so
this is a potential linked to antibiotic
use and malignancy which is something
that I've worried about for a long time
but again it speaks to the Acuity of
that process you're trying to cure
ulcerative colitis or put it into
remission or Crohn's disease that's a
long-term process those stool microbes
for C diff
you're able to control the acute
infection and then the microbiome kind
of reverts back to something closer to
Baseline gradually over time but with
colitis or Crohn's or Ms or Parkinson's
you need the microbiome those changes to
last and so in the studies where it
combined it with diet they saw very
different results yeah it was another
study that just came out just a few
weeks ago and this was a small study
from India looking at ulcerative colitis
and they did the fmt with dietary change
very dramatic results very different
results much higher rates of response
and of remission so it's intuitive Rich
that you've got to continue to feel you
can't feed the microbes Doritos and
cheeseburgers yeah it's it's like
planting a seed in the sand and walking
away from it and being disappointed that
it doesn't grow versus you know watering
it and feeding it and chilling the soil
and all of that I mean conceivably it
would follow it makes sense that even
with a chronic condition you would be
able to resolve it if you had periodic
fecal transplants on some kind of
schedule over an extended a very
extended period of time and a very
specific diet that is intended to
fertilize those uh you know those those
transplants so that they're allowed to
flourish and grow until they become sort
of self-sufficient right and the other
thing we have to consider is what is the
quality of the stool that's being
transplanted so is a stool from somebody
you know who's eaten at McDonald's calls
every day I mean the the vetting process
is very basic currently so they exclude
certain infectious diseases you know
they test for syphilis and HIV and
hepatitis and various things and there's
certain conditions that are will exclude
you from being able to be a donor and
medications but there's nothing about I
want to know like how many vegetables do
you eat right I'm seeing a new product
category you know on goop for this I
mean I always said if I were getting a
stool transplant I would be going to
Tanzania and getting some stool from one
of my hands of try brothers or sisters
right I don't I don't want
um stool from somebody who's been eating
at McDonald's every day so we don't in
the studies where they looked at the
Quality the microbial richness diversity
robustness of the stool you measure
short chain fatty acids that's night and
day it's like any other transplant if
you're getting heart transplant from you
know an older person who lived a very
unhealthy life
you're going to have a different outcome
or if you're getting a heart transplant
from a young healthy person right so and
you know in this case I would say age
maybe less so but because I would take
some microbes from Mike Fremont
yeah Mike you support himself for the
rest of his life selling his selling his
stool yeah so we have to look at what
are we feeding the microbes that are
being transplanted and
um what is the quality of the
transplanted stool and I think in the
future we'll see some new innovation so
we'll see instead of somebody else's
stool where we do have to worry about
infectious things and that's why getting
stool from an intimate contact can make
it more convenient right you're already
swapping body fluids but there may be
issues with the quality of the stool
there that are not ideal is can we
amplify our own bacteria can we take our
existing fecalobacterium presnet CI and
maybe take them out of the body and
amplify them in some way maybe with an
ideal growth medium and then reintroduce
them and of course Rich we can do that
with food yeah we could do that yeah I
mean that's the great thing is we don't
have to sit around and wait for these
moonshots to you know become accessible
to all of us there are all these things
that we can do every single day it's
back to the original point that we open
this conversation with with which is you
know the resilience of the human body
and the ability of the microbiome to
adapt and you know throughout your book
I mean as you've mentioned a third of
the book really is this plan right
you've laid out this entire plan it's
about you know mastering your mind
securing defenses changing your
environment rethinking these
Therapeutics and you walk people through
step by step very practical things that
every every one of us can do including
all these recipes these for different
kinds of foods that are you know
specific to optimizing our the health of
our gut and I think it's you know I'm
excited for people to read it I think
it's really powerful and it's empowering
and that's the point right it's not just
an academic pursuit to try to understand
the microbiome but to really give people
tools that they can Implement into their
lives to take better control of their
health trajectory and I think it is an
optimistic message I mean I I find it
reassuring this information you know
there's stuff you can do because
the fear-mongering you know when you and
that's how you sell stuff to people is
you make them afraid right and I'm not
interested in doing that I'm interested
in making sure people have the
information to empower themselves so
that they don't need my help quite
frankly yeah and if somebody is looking
for your kind of help you know maybe
they're not able to come and see you uh
but what is a way or a resource that's
available to people who are trying to
find someone who has your type of
specialty in an integrative sense in
their respective area
you know is there is there a way to do
that that's a tough one rich we don't
currently have
um sort of Association of Integrative
gastroenterologists so that although
will be and myself and Jerry Mullen and
um this great guy Desmond uh British
gastroenterologist who I met at icnm I'm
blanking on his last name but uh he runs
a clinic in the UK treating patients
with IBD plant-based diet so there's a
handful of us and we've been chatting
about it and um
you know it wouldn't it the idea
wouldn't be you have to be a plant-based
physician to be part of this not at all
it's just this idea of people who
believe in the concept of food as
medicine for treating digestive
disorders so
I think that you know you've got to ask
some questions and you might have a
gastroenterologist who maybe isn't
particularly focused on this but is open
to this and maybe you're working with a
nutritionist and the gastroenterologist
is open
and I think you know my Evolution from a
more I'm a conventionally trained
gastroenterologist but from somebody who
wrote a lot of prescriptions and you
know practice more conventional medicine
to somebody who now believes fervently
in the power of food as medicine and
what the individual can do in addition
to prescribing medication when needed
that Evolution really came because of
the patients who were generous enough to
share what they were doing with me when
I didn't know when I was like really
that stuff works and they're like yeah
this is I'm like how is it that you're I
scoped you and your ulcers are all gone
from your colitis what are you doing and
they'd be like well as a matter of fact
this is what I'm doing I've changed my
diet I'm doing this I'm focusing on and
so it was really
um you know a patient-led
Evolution and so I always tell people
like don't break up with your
gastroenterologist unless they're just
really an [ __ ] in which case
absolutely do but bring them along so
maybe you find somebody a nutritionist
who's well versed who can help and you
make sure that that gastroenterologist
is open to the idea of what you're going
to do and I always say tell them like
don't hide like say look I know you want
me to take this drug this biologic and
I'm aware that this could help me but
I'd like to try something else right now
and I feel like my disease is
sufficiently controlled that that's safe
for me to do you know do you agree and
this is what I'm going to do I'm going
to try this diet and I'm going to start
meditating and going for a walk in the
woods and whatever else and and we'll
see how it goes and if it doesn't work
I'm gonna come back and get that drug
that you're telling me could help even
though it could potentially cause an
infection to give me cancer because I
think I need it at that point but I'm
going to explore this stuff so I think
that we the the way we change the
medical community is we have to change
it from the inside and if everybody
abandons their doctor and seeks somebody
else out that's not going to work so
bring your doctor along
to open his or her eyes about what can
be done and create those bridges between
the other practitioners that you were
using or it may even be a book that
you've read but you know books are
fantastic but you you really want to
find that practitioner who can be on
that Journey with you I think that's a
really important part of it yeah
beautifully put the communication and on
the subject of books just bring this
book this is the galley cup it doesn't
have the nice the nice new cover on it
but maybe pick up the antiviral gut and
bring it to your gastroenterologist if
they haven't read it yet right the worst
thing that can happen is you improve
your health there you go
um seven years is too long in between
our conversations uh I have so much
reverence and respect for the work that
you're doing and you know the the
subject of the microbiome is just
endlessly fascinating and I think it's
really important work and the fact that
you've
found a way to communicate what is very
complex uh in a way that's not just
understandable but very practical and
actionable I think it's a great service
so thank you for that and it's always a
pleasure to talk to you and come back
and talk to me some more thank you Rich
and I just have to say too that you know
we've we've known each other a long time
and I've watched sort of in awe as you
built this incredible Community but I
also just want to
call you out for the what I think was a
really incredible work you did during
that dark summer of 2020 with black
lives matter and our country was really
hurting and still is in a lot of ways
but I think you personally just did so
much to um to move us along there so
thank you for that I appreciate that it
wasn't much but it was a little bit that
I could do during that difficult time so
thank you thank you uh
obviously pick up the antiviral gut
available everywhere uh any other place
that you want to direct people to yeah
so um learn more about you
robinshotcan.com I have a difficult to
spell first name
r-o-v-y-n-n-a-r-o-b-y-n-n-e and an
equally difficult to spell last name
c-h-u-t-k-a-n so Rob and chuckan.com
we're sort of transitioning from
godbless.com to robinchatkan.com and we
do have lots of great free resources
there we have these gut guides to
different conditions that talk about you
know diagnosis and and Therapeutics and
um we have a great blog with lots of
great tips and we don't sell anything or
promote anything right and you're I
think you're you're still God blessed on
some of the social yeah at Godless on IG
but planning attention
happening yeah cool all right well uh
like I said you're always welcome here
and uh thank you that was amazing and
wonderful thank you so much it's always
so good to be here peace
foreign
[Music]